this video is sponsored by liquid IV
more on them after the reaction
[Music]
people citizens of the reject Nation it
is time to get our hunger on with a
ballad of songbirds and snakes John how
are you I'm excited that's good to hear
John I think you're doing a reference
I've only seen the Hunger Games movies
one time but I'm ready to catch every
Easter egg in reference baby I'm going
to do it all watch guys we're going to
nail it what do you guys think of this
movie did you like it is it good does it
live up to the previous Trilogy leave
your thoughts down below you know what
to do leave a like that'd be great also
thank you to prepper for helping us set
down these highlights full length
Reaction watch long and where you sync
up with your own copy of The Hunger
Games the ballot of song birds and
snakes we cannot mention this movie
without mentioning the whole title so
anyway The Hunger Games the ballot of
song birds and snakes that is available
for our super sex reix at our patreon
page and over there we cover some things
exclusively with highlights and watch
songs included ready to get your game on
I'm ready to watch Hunger Games with
ballot of song wordss and snakes me too
let's Hunger Games Ballad of song Words
and
[Music]
snakes whoa the dark dark
days 3 years prior oh man and 10 years
before the first
Purge there's some food over here
quick
who
damn it's like a
Warg threat
eliminated oh
man the
[Music]
butcher why is he doing he's starving
cannibalism come in ignorance and want
your father is dead cor elanus it was a
rebel will they say trap out in the
forest that's why he hates rebellions
and especially why he hates
12 it's up to us now to make him
proud and he was just out in the
snow yeah
actually ooh finally going to learn
about my favorite dictator a child of
Fire 3 years later you got to grow up
fast in this Hunger Game streets where's
the shirt you don't need a shirt look at
you yeah don't insult us man look I did
it I I did something and you should
really eat something today save them for
Grand that you looks so handsome oh it's
going to be a tragic downfall of him
yeah it's going to be real sad when she
dies horribly future president of PanAm
We Salute You
just she is a real array of bright
energy though about the grades never
miss class 10 years is that why he even
Dean High bottom can't deny us this now
High bottom High bottom what's the first
thing you'll spend the prize money on
new dress more bleach for the curtains
chocolate
chocolate something so simple the plen
prize will be able to pay the rent
snowlands on top it does it does
gravitationally speaking but do flowers
grow in the
snow
D this looks great yeah that's a badass
[Music]
statue there's something excited about
returning to the world of The Hunger
Games yeah are you sweating it's reaping
day we gave driver the morning off that
ingr should be begging to show for you
around today just don't forget I was
your class partner while you're gloating
over the plinth Pride I volunteer as
tribute sorry he said driver so that's a
snazzy shirt what are those buttons Tess
that's why they remind me of the maid's
bathroom have you tried this land that's
scandalous only the Vault that he not
teach a table manners maybe he would
have if he wasn't so busy running the
country hey they called us here for the
plint prize right I hate all of you
guys plint and look at his
spawn who would have thought that you
could buy your way into the capital I
mean of course you can I don't like him
or acne I tolerate him his district as I
do with all plees I heard one more time
how immoral these Hunger Games are I'll
put them in the arena my
oh so Janus you made it to the reaping
for once and you made it to graduation
Festus we're both
shocked burned Hey listen I know you
have high hopes for this but there is no
price today not anymore what is that
supposed to mean got some inite insight
Intel oh oh Viola I am Dr volumia G your
humble head game maker in charge of the
war department and all its affiliated
cond con certain that is a credential
I've broken free of my laboratory to
examine you the leaders of the next
generation seems like an evil scientist
cross with like an eccentric old witch
or something yeah I am honored to
introduce to you the creator of The
Hunger Games themselves here we
go Dean Casa High bottom is he a drunk
does he know things I have summoned you
all here today for the 10th Annual
reaping ceremon
in which we choose two children from
each district to throw into the capital
Arena to fight to the death in The
Hunger Games he does not seem proud of
this and here sit our own 24 top
prospects all waiting to hear the
results of hard study in this
prestigious institution eager to learn
who's won that plin prize no doubt it's
all they can talk about I am here to
tell you that there has been a change
this year one final assignment to prove
your worth a tri wizard tournament the
esteemed citizen of the capital have
grown bored of the games and simply
aren't watching anymore and if the games
are to continue at all there must be an
audience head game maker Dr Gul has
stepped in to spice things up the plain
prize will no longer be determined by
who has the best
grades who is the best Mentor in the
Hunger Game oh he's going to Mentor
someone in the Hunger Games dang as the
reaping progresses live I will allocate
each district tribute a capital Mentor
behind the scenes one who must just
persuade them just to get them
emotionally involved obviously the best
Mentor will be the one whose tribute
wins the games what if I get a pathetic
run girl from one of the poor districts
like8 or 12 no he's going to die in 2
minutes like they did last year and the
year before don't be strictest Your Role
is to turn these children into
spectacles Miss crane victory in the
games is only one of our consideration
your entire future rests on this last
project that's how much they connect
with a contestant that anyone caught
cheating to give their tributes an
unfair Advantage we'll just have no
future at all cuz you be dead that's a
death threat Coro is going to get a 12
let the reaping ceremony begin I love
Peter Dinklage man yeah he just so great
boy everywhere go to Livia
cardo I got a good one how boy goes to S
Janice plen hey we got the pick of the
letter you forget I'm part of that
letter so brooding you never forget oh
oh he's going to get Rachel Z okay yeah
oh that's right she right
now 10 boy Deisha whims oh he's going to
get 12 he's got to he's got beef with
them District 12 oh he does belongs to
corena
snow look out you get the best looking
one man yeah and she could sing Lucy
gray
bear wow this looks like like when you
wait in line for a ride at uh Six
Flags yeah it's one costume character
and the rest of us pants talk about the
architecture sing your way out of this
one Lucy gray oh look out that girl got
beef what is that dress she's some sort
of clown hey I didn't know I didn't know
I'm sorry her makeup is on point got to
be even now you have to be playing to
the
people snake oh and she's the song
[Music]
bird a [__] I got a troublemaker help
her help not Emma
Stone
whoa
damn this movie is so woke hit women now
yeah gone that far into woke territory I
only want to see people hitting women or
B
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh he's gonna be
good there is a power to songs
man power of Harmony there's a Unity
some
prayer singing she out of her mind she's
already doing the show man
[Music]
oh the solders like let
let just don't tap your feet just just
don't Capital says keep
rolling I know dude he locked out she's
going to be a star yeah exactly oh this
mic is is here who who who who put this
mic
here he's falling in love you can kiss
my
ass
H
feisty got Moxy there's a
response what sup
[__] Lucy graybeard out proud I see
like your father you knew my father he
and I were best friends BFS 4 L your
makeshift shirt and your two tight shoes
trying desperately to fit in when I know
the Snows don't have a Pott to piss in
oh no wonder Dad and aren't best friends
good luck with that poor little
song Lucy gray won't survive a minute
inside that Arena so that means we have
to make every second before then
count I'll get her to sing again I
wouldn't sing a note for you if I was
her she's District Tigers she knows we
hate her and she wants us dead how am I
supposed to get her to trust me
manipulation imagine it was your name
that they p and you had been ripped from
your home don't discount her just
because she's distra you might have more
in common with her than you think he's
going to play the G game that he's going
to end up falling in love with her yeah
he's going to go against everything he
believes
in the
Roses the white roses I mean she seems
like she'd be smart enough to see
through any [__] though yeah she
seems like an already well established
[Music]
Rebel I'm Lucy Gray
you must be
snow welcome to the capital when I was
little my mama used to bathe me in
buttermilk and rose
[Music]
petals I eat your rose
petals I eat it up I'm your Mentor a
rebel what does my mentor do besides
bring me roses I do my best to take care
of you
no good luck with that gorgeous hey you
got spunk excuse me can I can I borrow
your gun
hey seeing the ugliness of the system
you help to
[Music]
perpetuate you really stand
out Ain going to eat you alive boy you
in the wrong cage no this cage is
delightful will kill you right now he'll
do it too Reaper killed a peacekeeper
back in 11 I say we all kill her I'm in
yeah this is a wild idea y'all got
family back home kill them if you hurt
him besides he's my mentor I might need
him how come you get a mendor you each
get
one oh no oh
[Music]
no protect her whoa what
the
Jesus oh right in a cage oh Jesus
Sportsman oh is he young Stanley Tui
he's young Stanley Tui flickerman I'm
lucious lucky flickerman a man who needs
no introduction you'll know me as your
favorite weatherman then amateur
magician hey the capital Zoo where this
year's tributes will be held here on
display Behind These Bars for your
viewing pleasure oh that is sick a human
dis yeah hello sir yes you in the red
who are you and why are you in there
with them we're
live be there their Mentor OH you could
use the relationship to help
Elevate Own It sing to them may I
introduce you to my neighbors response
would be appreciated but anything would
be nice he's going on back there hello
can they not hear me in
there sound barrier hi how do you do oh
my name is Cory Elena snow and this is
my tribute Lucy grey bar from District
12 hi there what's your name my name is
punches and I'm from kids interview
fans.com where did you find that snake
oh he found me must have been a music
lover must sing and calmed him WRA
down no one who might you be oh you
don't know who I am don't laugh not
everyone has televisions out in the
districts wow this is like if the purge
succeeded yeah seriously I'm not
actually from 12 know my people are cvy
we're like a family we're musicians by
trade and we travel from place to place
it's the fancy takes us at least we used
to before the peacekeepers rounded us up
she's got such personality do you know
my mentor his name is Corina snow and
clearly I got the cake with the cream
cuz nobody else has even bother it to
show up yeah I like you a lot she's
running the show the game makers did
tell you to jump in the cage with them
they just said that it was a mentor's
job to introduce our tributes to the
citizens of panm if Lucy gray is brave
enough to be here then why shouldn't I
be too for the record I didn't have a
choice yep that's important to note so
come down to the zoo and see these
tributes before it's too late and I mean
too late before they're dead I'm
lucrecias
lucky flickerman that is a hell of a
trick yeah how'd you do that I mean she
seems very capable and I she kind of
treats it like she's getting exposure
yeah for her music career yes she's been
planning this great way to get some
followers your little Excursion is in
violation of about five different
Academy rules Mr snow you I'm moving for
the game makers to disqualify you as
Mentor immediately wow what a jerk and
you ucing her to people you make it look
as if one and the same as those animals
a tributes are human beings just like us
shut up dude you're harshing the
vibe snow fell down in the cage down in
the cage but wow what is she doing
everything maybe one day you'll be a
game maker like
me what are the hunger games for they're
to punish the districts for their
Uprising they're for Ratings commemorate
the end of the war commemorate the dull
dull dull punishment can take Myriad
forms we need the emotion we be asking
ourselves whether or not they're right
in the first place we have a problem
with my game were 2 years old when the
war ended the oldest of them were only
eight you're not going to be a good
Mentor yeah the capital is supposed to
be everyone's government now it is
supposed to protect all of us now making
children fight each other to the death
is protecting anyone that sort of
sympathy might interfere with your
mentoring
assignment maybe s Janus is on to
something here maybe we should be
viewing those tributes as human
beings what I just wanted to get to know
Lucy gray like wanting to get to know a
lion yeah doesn't mean you let him to
make the stakes personal who will watch
the games if they care what happens to
the tributes everyone I watched American
Idol people need someone to root for and
someone to root against against we need
them to invest and if we bend a few
Capital laws we could even have them
place
bets wow you really instrumented
everything yeah a whole vision for how
this could be even better and even worse
how to create engagement with the hunger
canes I'd like you to write up a
proposal of these thoughts tonight Mr
snow wait you you might you might
actually use his ideas if it'll help the
ratings why
not corus and I are class Partners we do
all of our assignments to
what a snake jeez dude it'll be an
interesting test I mean what's the har
they're saying The Hunger Games aren't
working so you got to try something
different yeah why not emotional
investment this is the future right they
should learn their lessons from prior
marketing tips yeah but why does this
experience leave him so cold my
classmate back in too it's not your
fault to I know I'm so blameless I'm
choking on it father bought him for me
you know at the raping just so he could
show me that I could never go back to T
your father sounds like a yeah but being
capital is going to kill me so do
something about
it eat this
bread eat your bread sandwich quite the
rebel I am I'm bad
news don't waste your time the boy's bad
news is that for us it's lber
spread I'm not hungry you think I can't
hear your stomach growling just a
big you can't eat pred alone
man what happened to his neck bat bot oh
first night on the train he thought i'
give him
superpowers man bat he didn't sleep away
the whole journey cuz he was keeping the
bats off me so I get some
rest what the what one thing I learned
in 12 is that hunger is a weapon your
friend over there sure knows it that's
why I keep all the host here starving
yeah I might have a chance to help you I
might even be able to get the audience
to send you gifts in the arena food and
water to keep you going microphones a
recording studio you just have to try
singing again to win people over I don't
sing when I'm told I sing when I have
something to say we'll find something to
say the guards say you get money if you
get more people to watch and you say you
want to help me which is it both yes by
helping you it helps him you seem like a
good man Corina snow you have no idea
you're a good man Draco Malfoy sure
would have been nice to meet you under
different circumstances one of your
shows maybe yeah you could have had a
drink oh could have done it yeah knock
boots wow dude oh yeah go for it Jesus
who that was great whoa it's okay hold
on hold on look at me hold on it's okay
I'll get out this is not going to help
your whole thing with Jesus yep so she
did and the narrative will make it look
like that a Savage killed her yeah this
is how we Begins the war it was my fault
I suggested we get closer to the tribute
it wasn't your fault she sh like a
[__] this was bound to happen somehow
she's not a rebel Grand she's just a
girl trust me that one hasn't been a
girl in a long time wow oh is she hunter
from Euphoria I've been wondering she
looks familiar she will use you you must
use her or you'll end up dead in the
trees like your father yesh
such like a soap opera whatever we cut
to anyone who's not part of the the
players in The Hunger Games yeah you're
in like the most Gody places dealing
with like the most Upper Crust issues
yeah half these people probably do have
like a missing twin brother back from
the dead our president has decided that
the games must go on of course show
everyone the capital is unafraid of such
acts of Terror that be given into
Rebellion later this evening there will
be a special telev presentation of each
tribute to our audience to you know get
to know them have an hour to discuss
strategy I love how he just playing
Tyrion again I know just an American
accent Tyrion dress like a freaking monk
you may
begin I like his attitude though it's is
funny there's like a divide between him
and col and but he's probably going to
end up more like him than the others
yeah I'm going to win and for that to
happen we need to make you more
marketable attractive we need a glow up
for
you
oh rule number one cover your
mouth people really ain't old up
that are you okay wearing my mama's
dress is the only thing keeping me
together here it's like she's wrapping
her arms around me I cannot tell how
sincere she is or if she is
intentionally playing him yeah I need
you to sing in these interviews later
it's the night before the games and your
last chance to win people cheapers this
move's quick can't send you gifts in the
arena without their money maybe a guitar
could persuade Me Maybe you really want
to take care of me in that Arena corus
give me a fender start by thinking I can
actually win no death coat I know for
some reason Rachel zaggler is a
controversial figure but I think she's
the best part of this movie oh yeah I
mean she's really I don't know yeah
she's just full of this uniquely
specific distinct pointed life
yeah
oh these are the creatures in early
devel early in development that they
would put in the games yeah come and see
my new babies so she is like an evil
scientist
yeah my laboratory straight out of a
cartoon DD I know she was just back
there stealing Ariel's voice real quick
and now she's in here your proposal
which one of you actually wrote it well
there was was inspired by corus
yesterday of course his little wedding
idea yeah yeah so it's your s writing on
that page unfortunately my assistant was
St it there you go there mhm in line the
shelf of this very terrarium with it oh
boy so miss Dove coat retrieve it for us
won't you all consider your inspired
idea really smart really smart to speak
up canot canot read the room could
you doel get those they can trust hey
some smart people are dumb as hell if
you've handled their food for example or
if they've inhaled the sweat of your
palm on a
page retrieve
it why don't you admit the truth yeah
dude
seriously yeah wowe I want my enemies to
see a rainbow of Destruction engulfing
the
world will she die the pleasure in
breaking ground in one's researches one
gets to find out you better keep Miss
Dev coat's fate between us I don't think
her mother would be happy to learn how
she'd CAU the sudden flu
oh sorry I'm
late enjoy the
show I'm enjoying the weird experiences
I'm enjoying the plot a lot I'm enjoying
being back in the world a lot
technically I feel like everything is
really cool I'm still yet to really
connect with any of the characters yeah
that's the one part that I'm like I
really need that right sometime soon
it's kind of like a fantastic Beast kind
of Rachel Ziggler's the closest I'm
coming
yeah but right now I'm the part
emotionally I'm most compelled by is
just what's
happening there's other things
emotionally I'm I'm latched on
to
wowe welcome to the arena for the 10th
annual Hunger Games you have 15 minutes
to survey the space and discuss strategy
D you stick by me understand sir yes sir
hey
Lumberjack how Gladiator like this feels
actually just
you forming their
alliances
please please don't let me die in here
tomorrow wowe or today Jesus while the
mentors are there yeah this is all part
of the plan I
bet wow is this really happening right
now
yeah survey the
space wow
whoa
oh help me oh how crazy damn in your
position back for help who will the real
Mentor
be oh and she goes back to help him
she's the one I'm connected to she's the
best come on the gate's
open come on he would have saved you
a scrypto has some like really cheesy
dialogue
though they were on set like this is
really going to get to the people really
emphasiz is that you it fluctuates the
script in the dialogue yeah yeah look at
her go oh
wow oh no
Maloy who is she gray where is she she's
alive what happened it was a rebel
bombing oh they must have been planing
it for months four tributes were killed
everyone's terrified cor B is the last
that gives her better RS oh yeah she's
winning right
now Felix Raven Still's on my so boy not
Felix Raven still released a message
they said they wanted to tear down the
symbol of The Hunger Games on live TV
you think he's giving them inside
knowledge oh I bet he is he's the only
one peacekeepers are hunting him in the
streets but at least he has a better
chance out there than he would tomorrow
tomorrow they're not still going ahead
with the games oh no Lucy gray this is
exactly what you didn't want to happen
but she saved me love how they always
say Lucy gray I know she made it clear
can't just say Lucy not Lucy Lucy gray
Lucy gray come out here with that guitar
you song bird hey what' they get her
what' they get her did they get her a
hummingbird I do like the oh my God he's
actually she's going to sing I wrote
this song about a boy back in 12 and I
hope he hears it
[Music]
uhoh 100 donations
donations 15,000
[Music]
donations got some pipes
man I love Dark Country
[Music]
yeah oh damn it's a Johnny Cash tune
yeah Sting here thinking do they write
stuff for this or are these
covers wow who she got
the 1500 but you know still not bad
pretty close send is that a d no this is
a regular guitar now I don't love your
odds but may they be in your favor oh
way to own that line own that line how
wonderful is it tonight that we all get
to be here for someone's final
performance wow dude go to bed get a
good night's sleep you got a big day
tomorrow got a big day to die tomorrow
what I love about the Aesthetics that
they've done it's still futuristic but
they've taken like how the 50s imagin
the future yeah as like retr futurist
yeah and it feels appropriately like in
the past of the familiar world but still
futuristic to now yeah it's pretty
cool just nothing beats Jennifer
Lawrence fing at the mouth in
tears for a whole trilogy you know yeah
yeah yeah you know it's the real heart
and soul of the
games but hey man maybe Rachel Ziggler
break down and do like a crazy ass
crying scene she's great I love her
character no ideaone else just about her
I love her
she you're alive they have them sleep
out there yeah I guess so there's no
other like doors or anything there's a
hole down in the floor leads down to
some tunnels I've tried it and you can
disappear down there what moment you
hear that bell rang you ignore the
weapons in the middle and you run as
fast as you can for that hole wow I
can't let you die I love you you saved
me let
secret maybe she saved you because she
knew she needed you still hopeful during
the daytime but when it gets darks okay
when it gets dark I'll suum to the
darkness me it's okay I really hope they
got this shot authentically I am going
to get you out of here promise back to
the Cy okay
oh
oh oh he now ready is this real yeah
thank you good question that song that
song was payback that's all my old
boyfriend Billy to he was cheating on me
with the mayor's daughter whoa yeah she
got crazy jealous she had her PW read my
name up on that stage and now everyone
will know what they did to me
damn she must be using him or something
in some way I mean she just seems so
much kind of sharper and and kind of
detached from the [__] of this than
anyone else it is not a gift it's alone
don't touch it don't even breathe it in
because small amounts can be deadly and
there will come a time when you need
this when you need to act we all do
things we're not proud of to survive
yeah is Lucy gray doing that we going to
win this she C this a different shot of
her we're going to win this together
it's the electric
company
Hunger Games Hunger
Games chapter
two oh got a yellow flower today that
friend of yours plin you might want to
find him a seat near the door whoa cuz
he's about to be called out put on blast
I'm lucious lucky flickerman oh he's
perfect CU you can still see he's trying
to prove himself yeah in my hand an
envelope my prediction the winner to be
opened by me upon the Big Show's end but
how old Stanley Tui supposed to
[Laughter]
be how long of a glow up was that really
how much plastic surgery did he have
done enjoy the
show I do like like Rachel Z is my
favorite colon Iris colonoscopy snow is
great he's he's good I do feel like we
still needed some stronger scenes with
them before I feel like we need feel a
little bit by the Numbers they with them
glue to stick all this together but
specifically between the two of them
yeah was the part where I'm like I know
where the plot's going but it kind of
just seems like the mov like we know
where the plot's going but they're not
there a little more meat on it yeah or
that way I'm like o I hope I hope she's
not using I want to I'm more just like I
don't know I wonder instead of like oh I
hope more time to test their actual
relationship through other means or or
like have other things intervene that
force them to act off the cuff yeah cuz
that's like the core heart of the
struggle here the real
conflict and I do like how like
downscaled these games feel by
comparison uh yeah by a lot they're in
one
room oh no a symbol out of him yeah
Marcus guess we can all sleep better now
knowing he's off the streets oh he's
going to lose his [__] yeah you're
monsters all of you I'm on your side I
thought he was the kid from strangers
when we saw the trailer he does look
like thought it was the whole time game
mazzo shouts
out
2 1
[Music]
sing O then the movie get
begin
yeah what are you doing FR nah man she
can't leave her dude behind oh how
barbaric this wide angle lens too it's
just like a Royal Rumble in here yeah
who nice
yesh ah
Trident what's his
name oh the bow and arrow so many Easter
eggs that was an instant vomit seems
like it's going to be a very short
Hunger
Games oh Jesus
jeez just wandering around over there
wow what a great
[Music]
shot I killed a man with a
trident Rick killed a
guy uhoh oh what you're seeing now is a
live feed of security cameras come on oh
boy oh boy high and soft NE other side
pining in on Lucy graay pining very
tactical oh she can squeez through can
Jessup damn it dude pull him ah no no no
no kick him kick his faceing
high oh you can feel that like what the
hell happened her where they stab her I
would have stabbed her right in the butt
this my one
opportunity see what this is
like six tributes gone in minutes if
they keep it up at this page
we're going to be out of here in no
time
wow oh my dude is he asking for death
yeah send your money now once they get
your money Mentor can choose to send in
food or
water reprogrammed with facial
recognition this shures that your
package goes directly to your tribute
isn't that right Pap Herington yeah yeah
the hell out of my face the first drone
[Music]
oh cut her hand off wow yeah what the
[__] they did not master drone
technology hey the facial recognition do
it did its thing so we don't have to
worry about that anymore what do you
want from that girl nothing I want her
to live and the plen prize would be a
happy coincidence I suppose I believe
I'd be entitled to
it prize the girl how convenient you
don't have to choose between them ouch
who do you think makes that final
decision for the prize you so covet Mr
snow wake up even if Lucy gy beard
somehow wins it all I will do everything
in my power to Ure that you don't see a
dime why do he have against this guy
yeah what' he do to you how much how
much do you care if she lives now more
is that the answer more what did you
sacrifice to make sure she could live
and then she betrayed you I just want to
S oh boy you know what's in that
water what have you done to it I didn't
do anything Jess you okay I did I did
Endeavor to save you and to share this
space with you s breadcrumbs I believe
sustenance for a fallen comrade on his
final journey of District 2 Superstition
whoa I need someone to get him out right
now you should send peacekeepers in only
to have him bolt and hide like a rabbit
ug Felix Raven steal his fighting for
his life in a hospital Mr snow I will
not have these Rebels make a further
mockery of my games oh you get them out
unscathed I whisper your name in his
father's ear uh-oh and he has more power
than Peter Dinklage I'll freeze the feed
for an hour I estimate that's all we
have until the people notice
whoa all the manipulations and minations
of high society I think Gary Ross
directed the first Hunger Games movie
and Francis Lawrence directed the rest
and I kind of feel like this needs a
touch of what Gary Ross's Direction was
yeah where you really feel like you're
there on ground observing this yeah I
think I need a little bit of that grit
that Gary Ross brings
but this movie does prove that you can
continue on The Hunger Games movies and
World Without You Know Jennifer Lawrence
yeah you still make this is still like
an interesting film yeah and you know
you get your social commentary in there
sort of same social commentary the other
ones more
overt slightly updated to include drones
and facial recognition
technology I mean no they they just dro
Dro drones in the they did the drones in
the other one this is like the origin of
it yeah or something right they Che them
yeah they have those little like
thingies that'll bring you stuff they
work you need to go Coro I promise to
get you up I have to do this I had to go
where the cameras are you think anyone's
watching this do you want to fight these
tributes or fight for them because if
you want to make real change you need to
stay alive how can I make any change
from out there you're rich you're the
only one who stood up to go in that
class right yeah you got to lead the
Rebellion out there dog better hurry up
man come with me spend your father's
money do some real good I'll just be
another dead body in Gs one trust me
come on
man go
go oh jeez wow enjoy the
show oh my God you can't you can't kill
him yeah oh no I don't want to hurt you
yeah dude in the face
dog oh he
mad whoa dude this is bad this is very
bad move over the gate oh maybe
theate maybe that was a hint of the
disdain that he actually does feel
towards
them my father my father let the buying
begin I feel so bad for these spoiled
Rich Kids yes who clearly understand the
full extent of the system within the
which they exist it's weird when the
people from The Districts got when the
people from The Districts first got
reeled in they were portrayed as humans
now that the games started they
portrayed as like Savage
villains what the [__] just
happened or is it intention that when
you switch perspectives of that you know
I don't know you get what I mean they
stop being human and all us they were
just Savages yeah yeah yeah where they
all just kind of feel like a big gang of
like rabid feral people villains yeah no
I did definitely I I remember in the
other movies like them having this sort
of you know nasty gang mentality here
and there but yeah it felt like we were
fighting morlocks just now yeah see how
quickly civilization disappears yeah
fight or flight those tributes don't
have a choice I was talking about you oh
all your fine manners education
background she witnessed she witnessed
with the club who beats another boy to
death to stay alive yeah was a test you
want to protect people Mr snow protect
the games to govern them like your
father oh and it's essential you accept
what human beings are animals and what
it takes to control them
television oh oh got to make enough
Hunger Games money to save the rec
center they sent me into the Arena
tonight tigers are you okay I killed one
of the tributes damn and it felt like a
release powerful oh yeah look out you
got your first
taste I'm going back in yeah I got to
get back in there you don't have to pay
the same price just to survive people
can be good you can be good you are good
okay it's your villain origin story man
something scintilating occurred bobin
from District slaughtered wow people
cheering they aren't showing us what
happened to that little boy he clearly
was killed right there there's cameras
everywhere they said there were old
cameras liy probably just another one of
corals Fus sit down they haven't moved
an
inch or hunger dementia what' you do to
me ly what is he doing something's wrong
he he wouldn't turn on her
like what did you do to me what did who
do to you someone must have done
something folding it in itself wait look
the phone I think it's rabies oh my
rabies it makes you afraid of water send
him a drone scar him yes away from her
oh my Vick's going for her community pad
early I don't have any idea fly a drone
right into him what's wrong with me I
guess that's what I mean is like here
they specify
oh
oh yeah oh and then we offered her water
yeah like Mary Magdalene oh look out
yeah they specify drones from the war
here I feel like that's that's more
pointed oh
yeah well that's the thing is they do
have like gladiator weapons too like at
least inspired by the different casts of
Gladiators in ancient Rome packing it in
Lucy gray swarmed cornered M propeller
sending a
drone his community I'm going to flood
the room hey Crow do you mind if I take
this one not a
chance
wow
Jesus hey free water water
hydrate they must have should have
stipulated something it's a that's a
little too much involvement I think
yeah develop the telepathic
link it's a terrible hiding spot yeah
it's not a good high
ground do
now
oh
[__] me she seems like a good
person
yesh oh that trident is very
effective whoa oh damn so
smart oh you're
cruel oh you real cruel I legit get out
of these
balls wake up grab and put a little wake
up let me go up here they'll want to get
their water
yeah
what she can stab through that oh damn
did you get a finger in
there you really think you deserve that
water now Tanner let's all share the
water look you just said watch the
beam
H Coro it's w a [__] what oh no why did
she step out yeah come on
now seven tributes remain that's
annoying oh she's going to try to drink
the water damn
it oh that is
sad
he's just going to lay
down what happened maybe they'll all
just have a sip of the water and just
all over I got to hydrate my brain so I
can think
straight how could they not be viewed as
humans before I don't know well I mean
that's what classism does to you as long
as there is a ladder there will be
someone there to look down it and say
not
you or is he going to give them a
[Music]
p yeah man a little Mass
grave are you going to punish me
now my dude he's cool Felix Raven son of
our beloved
president sustained in the rebel bombing
wow no Phoenix Raven still they will be
celebrating this young boy's death as a
Triumph wow not allow my games to give
our enemy such a victory they will not
spoil the fun before the sun goes down
tonight a rainbow of Destruction will
engulf our Arena the rainbow of
Destruction it's back there's to be no
Victor in these game dude what oh boy
what is the motive here got to show
absolute power so this is a very pivotal
[Music]
game there a Tracker in him I need to
see Dr G
immediately yeah she's taking uh she's
completely open schedule right here that
announc video her phone's not been
ringing off the hook no one's tried to
this first one to try to
see I thought I would have visitors out
the
door no my stitches they broke close
come sit hold down your shirt yeah
Seducer song birds and
cages this might
hurt what are we doing here they got to
transport that to OC Corp Tower jabber
Jays we called them Ming J sent them out
during the war to pick up Rebel
conversations squawk it back to us word
for word wow whoa
cool that's really cool was there a bird
in in the arena there must have been a
failed experiment but an instructive one
I'm rounding them up District by
District now to see what better purposes
they might serve what a great form of
surveillance failed experiment but an
instructive one so are they fully
organic or digitally integrated or both
uh it's the hunger gam Ser
both
o i mean maybe I wouldn't be right next
to the vent yeah you got a whole lot of
space like you should at least check
that out over the one the one stabbing
spot baby you don't want to be
at oh yeah put the hanky in there so
they know her and they love
her that's not a bad plan it's one
little thing everyone's going to pass it
around yeah good mcgu snakes are all
going to pass that one little
C it smelled as [__] man SM I smelled
you before just smell as
[__] how much more heroin do I have oh
damn what's wrong with
Treach woo
boy oh boy Jesus oh boy
[Music]
no of the snakes yeah buddy Snakes on a
drone did every snake get a chance with
that
hanky
a oh yeah oh wow what a way to
go oh oh oh Jesus super snakes
they kind of look like uh the candy yeah
like uh the trolly
uh uh Creepy Crawlers candy
snakes it's not matter it's not I can't
have killed them all for nothing wow
that's what the system will do to
you Creepy
Crawlers and is goodbye to Festus Creed
have a nice summer now all colors lead
to
Gray he's like he's proud of himself
that's a good one it's a good one
flickerman we worship you oh
[Music]
graybeard oh no you're going to make her
martyr if you let her die man before I
can f
of don't you go she won it's over let
her out wer yeah why aren't they
attacking her must be the singing it's
calming them she can't sing
forever she got to sing with that accent
[Music]
too
she's moving everyone dude
yeah go
girl oh damn she she's scaring me
goosebumps like twice
man oh that
shot oh this is like like what legendary
stories are made of yeah big
sacrifices I wonder if they sang if she
sang this like on set in camera cuz it's
like so performed through the emotion of
her character get her
out get her out you're going to make her
a goddamn enemy call dude what are you
doing yeah dude make the call call yeah
get her out there go get her out get her
out
there was Lucy gray
yeah
get she's won Lucy gray for let us know
is the winner of the 10th annual Hunger
Games but Cory Elena still loses his
mentorship competition yeah there's
still like an hour left of the movie I
know what else is there to
do then he became an evil
dictator elect this man let him lead
us uhoh oh damn it uh oh you
cheated H yep cheating will be punished
yep yep yep isy gray where is she I
would be more concerned with your own
Survival if I were you we both know that
child from 11 in diet disease and that
old
handkerchief founded in the snake tank
condemning you with your father's own
initials
so it was still in the
tank yeah a handkerchief yeah they must
have just all passed it around didn't
get like Swept Away in any of that just
left it right there on the
bottom I've decided banishment to the
districts will you serve your capital in
exile for the next 20 years as an
anonymous peacekeeping grunt damn he's
going to make you a stormtrooper dude
you hear that boy
finally the sound of snow falling hey it
falls on top yeah snow falls top chapter
three snow falls on
top
whoa oh buddy a full on prisoner yeah so
James what are you doing what do you
think what I did in the arena my father
had to buy the academy a brand new gym
just I could get my
diploma begged me to stay but once I
found out where they were sending you I
couldn't get out fast enough my man
figure I get through basic and then
maybe I become a medic make a real
difference out here just like you said a
it's good to see you smile man I cheated
save Lucy Gray from the snakes and I do
it again do you think they killed her
she was a big hit if there is a games
next year they're probably going to
invite her to sing at the opening
ceremony a she's going to love that
when the girl you risked everything for
might be waiting for you at the end of
this trap my friend don't give them the
satisfaction your life has just begun
you're going to do great she has a whole
family name yeah how does a guy like
this climb back in power I mean he must
wind up being some in some unique
position to mediate between the furthest
reaches of the rebellion and the
innermost core of society must exploit
something welcome to 12 for the next
many years brothers and sisters in your
immediate Squad will become your family
you will train together sleep together
eat together you will rise together and
you will fall together touch yourselves
together and it will be your duty to
report anything suspicious you see
because if you do not you are as good as
a rebel yourself Burn Gorman a
peacekeeper and two mind bosses were
shot dead that this man all out chance
is
guilty
oh run run
ah you're
murderer the birds are listening spy
Birds yeah jabber what were you thinking
back there she didn't do anything Coro
what do she kill to you being directly
associated with Rebels if she had gotten
through the crowd I don't think I would
have been able to shoot her you need to
find a way to make peace with our life
here now W H's giving us all leave
passes for the weekend boost morale
we're going to Hogs me yeah they need a
morale boost yeah these guys clearly
downtrodden yeah does make sense though
like he would this whole experience
allowed him to get the most involved
with understanding the full breadth of
the whole society from Top how to govern
well how to govern over yeah how to
Wrangle and maintain
oh there's music Lucy Great Bear could
be
here
[Music]
here cuz we're planning on heating it up
a let's go no
one here we go get that new
guitar you need a bird you need like a
hummingbird or a dove like there a lot
of bird themed guitars I bet you never
expected to lay eyes on me again and let
me tell you that goes both ways but I am
back oh come on y'all you know I gave up
drinking when I was 12 I wonder if she's
been brainwashed or like controlled by
the capital in some way yeah leveraged
and or more likely leveraged than
indoctrinated but
[Music]
yeah
oh she got a great voice God damn all
them blue not like every song she's been
given yeah when she's going to bring
that
Soulful bluesy
quality with like Broadway
Precision are these original songs I
don't know if they yeah I don't know
like they sound like they could be just
like you know songs passed
down
it's go take I feel like the lyrics kind
of suggest that it's a it's an original
song like written recently but it sound
like they could be about her it could be
about they could be about snow like
Snow's
perspective get that accordion boy oh
Jesus swear you wouldn't play with them
again Billy
to B
Jesus oh dude
save the accordion ow I know you missed
me Luc keep your hands off me right now
oh that's the
xoh uhoh uhoh I will snake I
will oh dude yeah get off get off what
are you crazy come on we got
here wow was that close to her this is
really interesting there's like three
different movies in here yeah each Act
own little movie each chapter really
[Music]
interesting around the Hanging Tree
swaying in the breeze I love every kind
of song she was given yeah still got one
foot in the
arena God how beautiful the country
there is a bit of like a classic
southern tale they tell with her
breaking their rules saving your life
but I gave them my last scent so that I
could come here to 12 because I had to
try to find you cuz I love you my Dean
he told me the strangest thing he said
he was glad that I survived you what
ouch I didn't have a choice that little
girl D I know I thought it'd be one of
the others maybe you are not a killer
Lucy gr yes I am did what I had to do
you're
safe I don't trust anything around
her there are no bars preventing you
now your Peacekeeper friends I'll handle
this hey they can't see us together
there's a lake out in the woods a nobody
knows much of it except usby meet me
here tomorrow we'll go it'll be our
special place it's a romantic drama
between them it's funny it's it would
have been cool to see some of this
perspective on her life in the earlier
part of the story but I get why you
can't really put it there but I feel
like it might have been a good thing to
do earlier on for her character figured
you'd be a while so I decided to Spore
town with Billy to who's the other guy
with him I remember that the academy
watching watch everyone oh carefully
choosing when the way in are you trying
to help these people don't you think
they need help they lost the war s
Janice before they started that made
your family Rich throw away any chance I
might have of getting home someday just
because you feel a bit
guilty good point turn
[Music]
coming I wrote this song about
me oh my God they're in like casual
garb one
by the Drone Just Hits
him the Forbidden
Love red on black friend to Jack I guess
she just wasn't using him or something I
guess not it's just an actual romance
between
them D I'm going to get the soundtrack
yes it's great I love I love the songs
Mocking Jays we call them mocking
everyone cheered in the theater stood up
and threw their po that's part one and
that's part
two I'm sure she's out there somewhere
she's a Survivor but it's a mystery
sweetheart just like me whenever you
look down in the sand and see one set of
footprints Lucy gray was carrying you
the whole time would you really go back
though if you could to the capital I
have to you have no idea ug but I hope
you'll come back with me capital's not
for me is it civilized has Ord
The Hunger Games are order yeah what
cuss of course not what if this was our
life corus not here it's not coralus
it's Slim Shady
now I got a new name all right it's a
little early at M Ivory early for what
to eat the roots pretty little thing but
it's determined J all just like you some
people call it swamp potato I think
Katniss has a much nicer ring don't you
catniss everyone took out their guns and
fired into the
[Laughter]
theaters oh where where's the everin Now
find an
everan he misses Billy
tote do you this right here eat up
bread there's a gale coming
down hey Mitch could you pass me
that you can trust me I promise you that
if you can trust anyone in this world
you can trust me no those wide lenses I
maybe I don't know one of the best
things about what's happening with this
movie is I cannot predict what is going
to happen that leads to him becoming the
snow that we know yeah yeah there's the
one thing I I can't I was like obviously
going to live whatever but I I have no
idea what it leads to I received the
results from your aptitude test this
morning over your training records too
your performance is exemplary well the
other recruits can't read sir you're
General crus SS boy crus what did you do
to end up here I made an enemy sir I've
made a career out of ruining my enemy's
plans I'm going to help you son yeah I'm
going to reassign you to officer
training in District 2 you'll real wage
no nope train leaves in 10 days keep a
clean record you'll never see anyone
from District 12 again as God intended
this is an honor private not option yes
sir that that's actually a really good
line yeah totally said honor not an
option really speaks to the the tone of
this Society especially where are you
great we're fine tigers where are you
we're underground we had to move out
we're renting this place just for right
now they evicted you of course they did
Grand's fine I really don't want you to
worry I think I found a way out of here
I just have to make it through officer
training and two and then I can make my
way back to the capital I will fix this
don't make me
hope what HOH who you talking to I think
that girl who's caged Oh Yeah from
before them special Birds I saw you
talking to that woman in the jail if I
don't report you now you don't know
anything to report they know we're
friends you're going to get us both
killed you told me I could do something
you told me I could make a difference
well you're rebelling though you're not
using your power they're going up north
to start a new life far away from PanAm
they need money for supplies they told
me I could go if I got it for them you
could come with us you're giving money
to the locals do not record this dog
they're not planning on doing anything
dangerous okay it's all dangerous
they're just doing what anybody else
would do Coro the leader Spruce he wants
to get his sister Lil out of jailon Base
Hoff is going to execute her just
because she knows the man that they
killed dude you're totally betraying him
what if they catch you bringing this
woman off base it's worth the risk to do
the right thing for you it's never worth
a risk play the long game and don't get
anything done in the
process don't make me rescue you again I
don't need you to rescue me Coro boy
damn dude now just leave the recording
on for the whole transport
process like max out the memory on this
poor bird they're just doing what
anybody else would do cor you the leader
Spruce he wants to get a sister out of
jail
on do he like trim it down or is he just
going to send it as is he didn't do
anything wrong well yeah and she knows
about him going in already she suggested
that so I guess he's
fine but it's these kind of Acts that
would make her
not trust him and not want to be with
him Lu right yeah oh 100 100% I mean
this is going to drive them apart
[Music]
completely a she's sicking to you [__]
that's my girl up there she sing about
me that's my woman talk about me up
there now I'm now part of District 12
just let me get one last look at
you a snow is
born what are you doing guns sanus I
know there was going to be weapons Coro
they lied to me you thought they'd be
honest are you crazy there are
peacekeepers right out there there's
another one in here now too okay oh yeah
it's okay Spruce he's with me he I I
told him to come in here he's going to
he don't be wor she's okay Spruce she's
joining us too she's with me she what
quiet down neor I'll explain later it's
my ex I'm trying to get her back man she
be C my rebound making me look
stupid what do you think Lucy gray mom
talk no action hey how' you enjoy the
capital by the way what did you do see
yall at the Hanging
Tree whoa yeah buddy oh my
[__] yeah hell's breaking loose now what
did you just do well you just shot the
mayor's daughter son what did you just
do want a rebel before you are now freak
Dam this on Me Maybe I said pop down C
surprise coming Capital boy if I'm going
to swing for this you swing with
me oh no dude wow [__] it's The
Departed look at me you're going to go
back out on that stage and you're going
to sing you're going to get your goddamn
[__] together yeah my hand never shakes
you're going to sing like nothing is
wrong and I'm going to find us a way out
of this okay okay I I swear I swear get
rid of these guns now he's got to clean
up this mess if you breathe a word now
both of us we're finished so we go back
out there and act like nothing is wrong
you have to pull it together you came
here for me right we're
brothers so whatever you've done I swear
I will keep you safe wow he's making a
promise that he knows he's not going to
be able to keep up yeah those guns were
the only loose end besides the four of
us so we're going to be okay not a word
okay
okay at the end of the day he's only
going to look out for himself it's like
that Mentor ship slingshotted him into
just being a manipulator and a plotter H
is losing his mind mind the mayor's
daughter got shot in her boyfriend too
he's sending out every grunt we've got
to find the guns that did it
oo my palms are
sweaty on my uniform already we shall
find their murder weapons if the killers
are still in PM's grasp they will hang
before the week is
out oh boy you okay mayor's going to get
me killed G lus you already think it
it's me Billy tote mayther both dead
they cat Spruce no sanus to the Jus
won't talk how do you know that trust me
he won't yeah I'm so sorry I should have
dealt with those guns myself I have to
run north that really hope and the
others talked about if I stay here now
I'm as good as de what about the Cy they
can look after each other just wanted to
say goodbye be targets without me I'll
come with you I just learned Hoff is
sending me to tube for officer training
but none of that matters now you were
going to leave it's all PanAm as soon as
they find that gun they'll hang me no
matter which district I'm in I think we
got one 3 years I fought for the capital
during the war oh I was going to let
someone else take it this is the first
time I felt
ashamed oh get the other one up here
yeah it's a big old Gap
there Capital has received word via
Jabba J that these two men conspire to
break into our basis jail and flee North
a you messed up dude expect this of a
reel but not from one of our own this is
treas does he know who that's who's his
son is the leader Spruce he wants to get
his sister Lil out of jailon Base oh
that is
bad oh wow they played it but they they
didn't play his a part of the
Audio I feel like everything post The
Hunger Games of this has been the most
[Laughter]
interesting this is the part that's
breathing the most and also like doing
something completely different from the
other ones yeah
yeah dude you like straight up betrayed
him yeah dude this is all on
you this man is like Master at sneaking
I know there's a whole bunch of dudes
[Music]
around I love the songs in this movie
they are all so good and they they've
naturally found a way to like weave them
through the whole thing and it's like
not quite a musical but still kind of
cuz like it's yeah it's such a strong
element there's emotion to it man
there's movement it's like completely
rooted in the story and it creates a
tone to the film yeah it's rooted in her
emotion sure will be nice not to have to
kill anyone else up north though huh
three's enough for me dude why that
phrase who's the third what person you
killed lanus he said you killed three
people I only know about two do not lie
to me oh yeah my old self I killed him
so I could come with you clever yeah
speak poetic she don't buy it though
very clever man we're going to need food
let's catch some fish while we're here
storm clouds gathering over your
relationship if you want to fish there's
rods under the
floorboards I brought you this delicious
bass it break to you guys there's I like
I I like them both individually they're
is a lack of like romantic chemistry
with them though
yeah it's like fine it's like passing
great you know but I really feel like
this has to be compelling yeah you got
to like love the romance enough that
it's going to be completely
heartbreaking when the inevitable
happens the one you fired at Mayfair
Spruce must have known about this place
if we destroy that gun you're free you
can go back home no besides me ug you
wouldn't tell anyone of course not song
birds for singing I'm just going to go
dig up some catness yeah down by the
lake thought it was too early for that
the world changes awful
fast that grin it's still raining well
I'm not made out of
sugar I would love if this just became
an evil dead movie right now St was in
there with the guns he did
it come you'll
see m a scarf I do like the trajectory
of oh my god wow
damn is that
poisonous I said are you trying to kill
me after everything I've done for you he
did do a lot for you it's turning into
like a tense domestic
threr yeah there the movies doing
something really interesting where he
starts off as like you know that pompous
arrogant first class and then the more
he becomes like the dark villain the
more human he actually seems yeah you
watch him flirt with the different
ideologies until finally we get here but
he seems like more like a guy now than
he did at the beginning even though he's
worse yeah he's
like becoming like full a
villain wow what a
shot went right for for it
wow uhoh something to remember you by
that's enough Lucy great I
said birds whistling along is it a
recording I don't know I guess must
be oh oh that's what I spend my time
doing in Red Dead Redemption damn Birds
he got to shoot the
birds it's like the saturation tone down
there then Jason comes
upks it's the only thing we haven't done
with Friday the 13th yet Jason gets a
gun
gummy berry juice I mean he got rid of
the loose ends of the guns but he would
need to kill her yeah especially
now how's the arm private medic said you
took quite a bite nothing that I won't
have forgotten about by the time I
reached tomb there's been a change of
plan private snow what we're creating a
special district and putting you in it
it's 15 congratulations Mr snow
you've passed all my tests so you'll be
studying under me now at the Capital
University what was the rest of the test
I can't afford University a certain Mr
stro plinth has offered to pay for
everything you need while you're there
wow all for being such a good friend to
his s Janus he doesn't know quite how
good a friend you were of course yeah
you sent your only friend to the Noose
just to get impressive that's not what I
did are you sure because I think that
won you the plin prize after all wow
whoa what a curse president has agreed
to another year of the games people
watched we got picked up but before I
take you under my wing after everything
you've seen out there in the real world
let me ask you one final time what are
The Hunger Games about what are the
Hunger Games for I used to think that
the Hunger Games Were punishment for the
district then I thought they served as a
warning to us here in the capital about
the threat the districts posed little
bit each now I know the whole world is
an arena and we need the Hunger Games to
remind us all who we truly are we need
the annual Purge who are you do you
determine the Victor welcome home Mr
[Laughter]
snow
wow the world is The Hunger Games you
look just like your father corus in the
end he became his father and we know
what she thinks of his father we
know she wasn't talking about the
clothes he was wearing talkinging about
the hate in his eyes your Twisted
Soul wake up sanus plint personal
effects from District
12 what's going going to return this to
his parents tonight as a gift would have
been his 19th birthday but I think they
would prefer just this H Jesus best
friends forever you grew a heart in the
districts no not in the districts in The
Hunger Games I should be thanking you
credit for the Hunger Games goes to your
father half of it at least I only jumed
them up as an assignment
whoa oh no oh my
God I was drunk devise a punishment for
our enemies so extreme they will never
forget how badly they've wronged us no
one could actually agree when I sobered
up I wanted it destroyed but your father
my best friend sto from me wow damn put
both our names on it taking it to G to
rise up himself she put it in a snake
tank I hope the games might die out I
tried to stop them however I could but
then you came along now the blood of so
many more Generations will be on my hand
hands yeah my contacts informed me that
she's disappeared that the mayor might
have killed her out there but there's no
proof it's mystery she is a mystery her
daddy's name look at you air to the
plint fortune Nothing in Your Way snow
lands on top God damn right got to
respect the game yeah that's true
respect the game don't knock the
hustle oh no Peter Dinklage man he did
seem like he wanted it the from very
beginning or
like
yeah surrender find your
peace
whoa that was a good effect actually the
way they made him go like cold and
purple and bruis around the eyes yeah
it's really
good color fading from his face
snowfall symbolism he's changed the
entire weather pattern of the capital
soon this Fountain will be covered in
ice and a rainbow of Destruction per
it's the things we love
most D Tri
us
oh look
out and you love Lucy gray the
theme awesome we did it we made
it wow all right reject Nation so today
I want to share something with you that
has been a wonderful addition to my
health and fitness journey that I
discovered during the holidays and that
is liquid IV's hydration multiplier I'm
down to my very last packet and I'm
freaking out but it's okay I got more in
the mail now a lot of you have been so
kind to notice how I've been working on
my physical health thank you for all the
compliments and one thing I learned is
that proper hydration is absolutely
crucial especially post-workout and
pre-filming after post-workout and my
wife actually introduced me to this
product which is perfect because we not
only care about quality but a good taste
and quality product whether it's after a
sweaty workout or just after you know a
good night out you know what I'm saying
efficient hydration and replenishing
electrolytes is key you just feel better
and it tastes fantastic I can't
emphasize that enough another thing I'm
always on the lookout for too is
products that have zero sugar or zero
sugar added because that's one of my
main dietary restrictions throughout the
week and they of course got products
that fit that description that also
tastes good too so yes thank you so much
so liquid IVs hydration multiplier is in
summary is they are non-GMO electrolyte
drink that delivers hydration into your
bloodstream faster and more efficient
than water alone sometimes drinking a
whole gallon is not always efficient but
in fact it can provide the same
hydration as drinking two to three
bottles of water I'm also big on
efficiency plus it's packed with the
love essential vitamins and we know
vitamins are good for the body it's
vegan soy free gluten- free and dairy
free you can customize the water amount
to your taste again perfect for post
night recovery traveling or just having
a big night out you know what I mean no
so if you want a booster support for the
channel and booster hydration game go to
liquid i.com and use promo code Rejects
at checkout that's liquid i.com promo
code Rejects and remember liquid IV it's
not a real IV sure feels like
it so stay hydrated stay healthy and
let's keep crushing those health and
fitness goals together in the year 2024
all righty well well reject Nation uh if
you're listening to us on Apple or
Spotify we just literally moment to go
finish watching Hunger Games Ballad of
song birds and snake
all righty well um before going into it
my expectations were they were tampered
well like there was a good trailer and
then there were not great reviews mixed
reviews I would say but then a really
good audience score and then the box
office ended up picking up on it so I
was like all right well this sets my
expectations I feel like that's all I
really knew I didn't watch any reviews
so I didn't know what people thought
about anything in
particular and then I just was able to
take this one down now just little
reminder like I've only I think I might
have seen the first one twice I think I
saw the first one twice yeah yeah I
definitely saw the first one twice and
then I saw the other ones just one time
and uh I really love the first two a lot
I remember uh really loving them yeah
this isn't going to be really a
comparison uh to them there's no real
point in doing that uh but there were
there's a lot about this movie that I
really really liked uh quite quite a bit
and there are some things that I'm like
H I feel like maybe they wor maybe two
and a half hours is actually not enough
to tell this epic spanning tale that
they want to tell and then it seems like
it even ends at a point where they would
still do his equal yeah to the the the
rise of snow I think they were smart
enough to go we'll just try this one
movie that we jam-packed out and then if
people like that then we'll do our corol
is snow Trilogy yeah yeah yeah instead
of announcing it ahead of time I mean
but what did what are your what's the
first thing that comes to mind for you
John oh goodness I mean I guess Rachel
Ziggler is the first thing that comes to
mind uh yeah I quite enjoyed this too uh
in an interesting way cuz yeah like The
Hunger Games franchise for me you know I
I like I probably had the same
experience that I think about it like I
might have seen Catching Fire or the
first one again at home you know on home
video at some point but I feel like I
the first one was a pretty vivid
experience when it was out the second
one like I'll never forget the IMAX
experience of that yeah and then the the
the returns you know kind of diminished
across the mocking Chase uh but yeah so
I I I came in kind of in a in a middle
space you know sort of being like yeah
I'm I'm happy to go back to this world
I'm not expecting the moon and I've
heard enough mixed opinions some people
really positive some people kind of met
that I was like yeah this this is a fun
Prospect to me because it could go any
number of directions and it sounds like
they're at least trying something and uh
and yeah like it's interesting because
those two performances at the center of
the movie are so much of you know what
makes it compelling I mean like the the
the world and the way that they talking
about snow and Lucy gray yeah okay Lucy
greybeard uh you know those two com I I
I I agree when you say that this could
have been longer just because I feel
like we really see from the perspective
of snow we really get to know snow and I
wish we could have maybe done that for
Lucy gray as well because Rachel zler
does have this fascinating presence in
the movie as it is presented because she
is kind of like a bird flying through
everything uh because she's removed from
everything like she comes from these
people who exist outside of and sort of
in between the different districts and
then you have the district setup that we
know about but we're largely seeing from
the perspective of somebody who is from
that Upper Crust and who you know has
even if he's got you know uh shambled
Origins is certainly Arisen to you know
the kind of the heights of privilege and
whatever else in this society and so
like when they first meet and she enters
the plot like she is such a presence and
such a force but I feel like there it's
like the problem is we need our own like
Katniss everine Style movie to show her
life outside of this too cuz like the
way she enters the movie she does have
this kind of like magic presence cuz you
know she's going to teach him but she's
also got to survive the Hunger Games but
she also just has this just sort of
effervescent wiseness in in all
situations that sort of places her I
don't know yeah just in this interesting
plane above it all while still very much
entrenched in it all so yeah I feel like
some of the character things could have
benefited from the kind of breathing
room the third chapter gets which I'm
glad they put it there because it's what
you're going to leave people off you
know it's the last taste you're going to
leave in their mouth and it's certainly
sort of a very
tangible uh sequence uh that part of the
story and you do get more of that sense
of like the life that this girl comes
from and and the way he looks at that
and all those interesting things but but
the performances I thought were really
terrific the performances were I thought
everyone was great in this movie yeah
even to even Viet Davis are usually
can't do anything wrong with me she's
the only one I was questionable about
did she did she for sure
know the world the tone of like yes
there are HID in characters in Hunger
Games for sure but there's kind of like
a time and a place for where they are
placed she's not doing like hoyy toyy
heighten she's doing like she something
else yeah she's doing like a whole other
she reminded me of Charlie there in Snow
White and the Huntsman where she's just
like way elevated and chewing scenery in
a way most other characters are not yeah
but I found it very amusing she was very
entertaining and she had her scenes
where she was effective yeah and I I
like I think for me you know while we're
on this subject of all them yeah like I
think the individual performances of
both of them were really good who plays
Snow yeah what is that guy's name i'
never I don't know if I've seen this guy
before probably have he's one of those
guys probably I'm like oh yeah I have
but I didn't I didn't remember has he
done a game of throne or something I
don't know this guy's name yeah Tom blle
Tom ble that name sounds familiar does
he maybe get like thrown out there for
lots of things no I haven't seen
anything this guy's done actually
looking at looking at his list of stuff
I haven't seen any of this yeah damn
first time this is first time for us
yeah first time for us uh yeah I mean I
thought he did a really good job and I
thought she did a really good job and I
think like the missing piece for me
between the two of them uh really was
just and a lot of it comes down to the
writing the breathing with then your
first um because there's three parts to
hear so three long acts is what they're
doing and and I think like in the First
Act especially they really could have
utilized building that relationship up
yeah with
them it's more about like the
qualitative treatment that you give them
with The Spar time they are allowed to
see each other you know and they're
talking about like oh Mentor mentee uh
Dynamic and they don't really I I don't
feel like we really did enough with that
that the part where I felt like they
were really missing something when it
seemed like that would have been your
most compelling story to element to
build the relationship between the two
of them because they want to do two
things right they want to tell the story
of the origin of snow but also the
origin of how The Hunger Games came to
be I think the one thing I was misled by
and I kind of blame the trailer I think
the trailer makes it feel this way that
this was going to be the first Hunger
Games yeah I thought I thought this
would be the first that was the
impression I was left with was oh we're
going to watch the story of the very
first Hunger Games yeah and what did
that look like yeah I didn't realize it'
be 10 years in we still get the origin
of how it came to be and and how it even
correlates more with snow haha in a way
that was uh pretty
surprising and it like that reveal at
the end of he is a special yeah your
dadicated these games your father was
Obi-Wan Kenobi yes you are monarch son
yeah yeah there was there was the a nice
little treatment there uh but I I do
think that what they did miss out on was
really capturing that to hide in
everything tension Stakes the that
prequel fear syndrome where you're like
I know he's going to be bad but I don't
want him to be you have to like tug at
that you know and that's where I thought
some of the qual where where some of the
emotional heft was missing some of its
zest yeah oh good word personally that's
just my personal take and it's kind of
odd to say that when the individual
performances themselves like isolator or
I thought were really good Rachel zler
especially I thought was a scene stealer
and and I I know you keeps I understand
your perspective there of wanting to see
a little bit more from Rachel Ziggler's
POV but I I this choice to keep it this
whole thing feels like it's entirely in
Snow's perspective even when you cut to
Rachel zegler in the arena or hiding out
I'm like well there's cameras on there
that he could be watching you know so
it's still his perspective so like even
choices like that make sense to me I
don't I can't recall a scene in here
where you actually cut away from a scene
that he is not either privy to or uh
like he has to be in the room in some
way yeah yeah and and honestly I don't
beg grudged the movie I understand that
the structure they've chosen
necessitates that and I don't think
that's the only way to do it I feel like
yeah if the First Act and by extension
the second but like one thing the later
games the earlier movies do which I get
is not fully formed yet that's part of
the point of these but you know you
spend a distinct amount of time with the
mentors you know so like and then they
become distinct characters and so
I like the idea of them being thrown
together and them essentially like
meeting as she's getting off the train
then being thrown into this truck and
then being thrown into the zoo and I
feel like if we could have stole in a
few more moments to it's weird it's like
there are a lot of things about it that
necessitate that quickness of pace and
we're rushing into this and there's not
really much time anyway but it would
have been nice I think to have a couple
of scenes that just made it so that we
maybe didn't have to spend so much time
wondering if she is you know being
straight with how she's expressing
herself cuz there are certain times and
and I and I think there's a certain
amount of time you're supposed to be
wondering oh are they both playing the
game um and and you know seeing from his
it's weird yeah it's it's good like I
think they've given us a good amount of
like kind of Rich stuff there but yeah
like some more intimate beats early on
that breath the little that allow them
to establish the chemistry and allow us
to Care just about them being together
Beyond all of this well the the issue I
think with the movie is is another even
though it's a long movie I mean nowadays
it feels like the standard for films are
like two and a half or three hours and I
think this should have been three hours
because unlike the other Hunger Games
movies specifically referencing the
first two those first two that Fe like
mocking jay does not have a Hunger Game
in it those first two movies have a
Hunger Game in it and the structure with
that is introduce characters lead into
the h games the fun ceremony stuff and
whatever and then you're in The Hunger
Games and there's like a a 5 to 10
minute wrap up at the end yeah those are
both those movies yeah you know and then
here you're do it all that and then
another hour whole movie The this is the
rare time because people used to roll
their eyes about the whole like oh split
the last one into two but I'm like you
could split this in two and really stack
up all the because all those happen to
favor one side or the other there's
always one half that's a little more
action-packed there's always one half
that's a little more emotional a little
more story and stakes and so like I feel
like here you could have had your
thrilling first installment of like oh
man we're getting to see the both of
them we're getting to see him learning
how this world works and his place in it
and the moral implications of all that
plus them just bonding over getting
through this Hunger Game and then the
next side okay they're free they're back
in the district they're about to gear
this up again you know will he you know
we know where he's headed but then you
can spend that movie going oh will they
remain you know together yeah cuz I
didn't even feel I I don't really care
for
um I'm not one of those people who
really thinks that a movie needs to do
commentary I do think that when you are
I'd rather just get a character-driven
narrative honestly more than anything
else and then let some commentary speak
via through that which is how I think
commentary generally should be ex it's
called
subtext yeah exactly because there's a
lot of textual talk in here yeah whereas
uh here I'm like the concert doesn't
really do anything that new for The
Hunger Games world uh not really like
everything that they touch on with uh
oppression classism and War all that
people as animals and you yeah like
prisoners the the way they've explor all
these Earth yeah we've seen all that and
and honestly that's the thing with
Francis Lawrence who I feel like is on
the unlike unlike David Yates because
David okay for those who don't know
David Yates made Order of Phoenix I
think that was his first one and then he
just made every Harry
Potter fantastic Beast he didn't take a
break to do anything else yeah whereas
Francis Lawrence has at least done stuff
since the last Hunger Games movie and
and then this one right but at the same
time it is like I feel like we kind of
needed a fresh director to I do feel
like because the first two acts while
not bad I don't think they're bad I
don't feel like they're anywhere near as
interesting as the last act because
there is a certain element of kind of
going by the numbers while they do some
different things even like the new stuff
that they're introducing kind of feels
like yeah this is about the Beats you
expect them to hit with the origin of
snow in this early Hunger Games story it
it does feel a little bit like in terms
of
outlining and and that's where the
richness would come in with just
stronger scene work or or really be like
even not being like I don't even really
care about that stuff being like the
outline being a little bit what I
expected it's but the scenes themselves
really shine and and so that's where
predictability versus uh you know actual
storytelling you and and to me I'm like
yeah it was kind of weaving in and out
uh for me of being really connected
whereas like the third part three of of
this post The Hunger Games is when I
felt like Francis Lawrence finally like
lit up yeah I was like okay I get to
bring some of that stuff I've probably
been raking in from more recent
experiences and apply it to this yeah I
got to do something different cuz to the
movie's credit one of the best things
about and and and I keep forgetting it's
actually based on a this one's based on
a book you're forgetting that but to the
story of it is there's been a lot of
origin Tales of people that just seem
unnecessary or I I don't even like that
word necessary you know when people say
that this fil is necessary I don't
really like that word necessary um that
the the origins feel
so predictable the origins feel like
well we know we're going to go here we
know is going to happen we know and and
the only thing we really that was a
obvious is that he's got to end up a bad
guy by the end and B um it probably
something to do with the Heartbreak here
that he experienced with this but the
way that
unfolds while some stuff you can sort of
telegraph like a like several minutes
before it happens for the most part I
really was like I don't know how he's
going to end up to being the snow or or
at least end up on the path of being the
snow that we know him to be by the time
he becomes Donald southernland yeah and
I thought that was a strength that kept
me watching because I was because I
could not see it really I'm like I don't
really know and by the time we got there
it actually really clicked for me it I
thought it was great on how they did it
cuz they took Avenues primarily in the
part three act they took Avenues and
directions that kind of let plot points
unfold in ways that don't actually feel
cliche and I don't think they are cliche
they took different directions that I
thought were actually really unexpected
of why he does what he does or how he
lands where he lands where he does come
to the lesson of the world is not the
Hunger Games are merely a mirror you
know and I thought that was kind of
powerful I thought that was great it's a
distillation of everything that's going
on all over this place because we
isolate the Hunger Games but they are a
reflection of us in a in a way right and
so I actually really like the third act
really bumped this up a lot for me
whereas the first two Acts were I I'm
I'm picking and choosing what I really
like well the first two acts of that
Blockbuster thing that happens where you
have like a bunch of talent and not
enough you know time to really let that
spread out yeah and and Ian even the
hunger game itself was like just yeah
it's a little It's Kind honestly it's
this a weird word to say a part of it
feels like it's kind of cute to me of oh
yeah it's like an older version oh yeah
look at that it's the older version
that's how a lot of it was sort of
reading yeah instead of really having
the suspense and stakes and the Menace
people finally the most violent [__]
that happens is someone people fall you
know like and I thought oh we're in a
more like barbaric setting where usually
we're in this like giant landscape yeah
and I and and and I and I thought it
actually completely didn't have the no I
want to say completely it was void of
the grit that the other ones had even
especially the first movie's grit like
the first movie I remember not knowing
what I was going to go watch and sure
there might have been like the shock Val
of it of someone who had no idea what
the Hunger Games was about and be like
these kids are married like but see but
it was still captured in a way that I
remember being like this is really
violent these are like kid like the way
it was being sh even pg3 Humanity of it
all yeah yeah like bord personally it
borders on R and and and and this I
thought really should have towed the
line and it The Hunger Games themselves
were like
yeah fine
that's that's the thing about so much of
the first two chapters of this and why I
do honestly think that if any of these
should have been split into two this
would be a good candidate because that's
the thing is I yeah it's like I think
it's a neat idea of doing like okay so
it's like the 10th one we've done a
couple of these enough to know that it's
not going to be like completely
makeshift but yeah it's not what you are
used to in the future that's a cool
Prospect because you can play up the
humor like with the drones but I feel
like the half that they are missing is
the way which that's totally more
barbaric or it would lead to a games
that is a lot more feral and Scrappy and
like that there are glimpses of that
like the weapons do like hearken back to
like old Gladiator stuff and you know
it's not super Hightech but I feel like
surface though it it it is yeah and and
so you have these cartoon you know all
the other competitors fell into their
cartoon you know archetypes and you have
like a literal puppy killing with the
one girl with the tuberculosis and the
one guy over here who's just like you
know
The Chosen hero and everyone in between
the problem with the runtime is that you
you're now short in like the other two
movies that's most of the runtime is the
it's the game and here you're like we
got to condense that runtime because
yeah see again not I guess I'm just
gonna Embrace that these are the ideas
the movie is giving me not to like
totally rewrite but I feel like it's
good to keep it in Snow's perspective I
I like what they tried to do with The
Hunger Games I feel like you could have
done a lot with the tension like you
could show her perspective in the games
to a greater emotional degree and and
ride off the simultaneous nature of the
fact that he's in one place around the
establishment watching her and can only
do so much to help and she's you know
literally stranded in Lord of the Flies
right now so like there's so much Mutual
tension and cutting back and forth and
stuff that you could do in the moment to
really make that gripping and and again
like one thing those old Hunger Games
movies did do was at least take some
time to like okay we're meeting all the
other contestants in they get their
intros in front of the city but then we
do like the behind the scenes like oh
this is what they're really like and
this is you know who I'm up against and
who might be an ally and you get to
wonder about all these things a little
whereas this is moving so quickly that
it it just doesn't give you time for
mystery or wondering much of anything
that isn't clearly going to be end of
the movie Reveal stuff and that's where
I think to your point of where some of
the stuff of because we're focused on
snow Snow's perspective not um uh Lucy's
perspective where Lucy gray whereas the
movies are focused on Katniss's
perspective who is in The Hunger Games
yeah so you you're more connected to it
you're you're more connected to the
entire thing and so I think the idea was
to kind of flip perspective but it was
trying to have its cake and E to two a
little bit you know and and I think
that's where some of it and because of
the fact that it's this number
installment
movie the only people who are going to
watch I most people who are going to
watch this this is going to be the
fourth Hunger Games movie they're
watching no the fifth this is GNA be the
fifth Hunger Games movie because there's
the MJ's two parts right yeah yeah this
will be the fifth Hunger Game movie
you're watching and not uh their first
one so you naturally well yeah know it
does and that's the thing is there is an
awaren too so yeah cuz yeah I think too
it's like it rushes pretty quickly past
them their initial distrust and the
spirit they suggest upon their first
meeting just doesn't seem like someone
who would warm up to him that fast so I
feel like they needed to earn moments
like that and yeah you can do a lot of
things still within his perspective but
that develop that that's what made him
uh that's what made me like question her
but back to her I mean I think that her
Rachel zler again and I feel like that
it's become like this hot Buton keyw
word to talk about her um I don't really
care I mean I I thought she was the
absolute standout in this movie I came
in here to watch the origin of The
Hunger Games and the origin of our
favorite dictator and Rachel zler I I
forgot she was in it till a moment
before they showed her I was like oh
yeah Rachel zler is in this movie I was
not expecting her character to be such a
standout her the songs that they I don't
know if they wrote those songs I don't
know if they're uh at um covers I don't
know what regardless I thought they
helped serve the narrative and help
develop her character and her voice and
the mood how it creates an atmosphere
around her and it's something that I
think could have really failed at how
they executed it to be in here is just
something that feels completely cheesy
and silly uh yet you can see how that is
also the start and origin of uh of
something theatrical to endear you to
the audience in terms of like in The
Hunger Games world of how they do that
the theatrics to make them a little bit
more performers who are tributes the
tributes make them more performers and
and uh but but her performance overall
like I was most concerned about her like
I didn't she was the only one where I
was like oo I I don't want her to die
and the stakes are really real for for
you cuz you're in district 12 at the
moment and you're also you know part of
a traveling group of people who seems to
be on the fringes of society anyway and
and I like that they use the music like
the music does I think a good amount to
bridge some of the gaps because music
does just speak in ways that words don't
always and and a lot of the lyrics kind
of are directly about situations that
happen but I feel like you know the
emotional rousing that music can provide
is put to good effect here and I like
that it also plays into the tradition of
like yeah in rebellions music plays a
big part both for morale and for this
sending of messages and other things
like that and so like that's a nice
astute detail to put in there that's
perfectly in line to do what often
happens in in earlier Hunger Games
installments where it's like okay this
is technically a rebellion but you can
warp it into being part of the show too
you know the the one is part part of the
Matrix you know yeah uh and so yeah like
that was like a cool thread that they
didn't have to commit to to the degree
that they did I thought that was like a
nice artistic surprise they put on this
it was a really nice artistic surprise
and I like The Descent of snow where
he normally in these movies where
someone becomes a monster you just
watched them become less human and more
cold by the end and I thought the choice
to actually do do kind of an inverse
where he actually seems more detached
honestly in the beginning to in the be
in the very very beginning of the movie
he seems a little bit more detached and
I get it his family was once of
prominence and he's putting on sort of
this like posturing Act of Elegance that
even Peter Dinklage calls him out on
yeah and then so then you're slowly
getting to see like oh he's actually but
some of his earlier on scenes I didn't
really I feel like he was cast for what
he did in the later half sure and not so
much what he did in the first half and
in that first half um yeah cuz I I think
his real strengths were in that last
half and in that first half of the movie
you you are watching as he's becoming
more human right from falling in love to
the fear and paranoia even when he
starts doing villainous Deeds or
corrupted Deeds that are out of just
selfish gain it where he's playing his
own Real World Hunger Games like as
someone who was a mentoring he playing
Real World Hunger Games he actually
feels like he's becoming more and more
human as he becomes quote quot unquote a
monster I guess you know and I and I
thought that was actually a nice way of
doing an origin for like oh look at him
he's a good guy and we're going to watch
him become bad and they did it in a way
that was different it didn't feel like
he completely
became sometimes in origin movies they
they really Telegraph very early on that
this is who they like oh you're going to
see them become bad and is Right streak
was always in them yeah yeah they do
that or they uh I don't know there's
there's all other kinds of versions of
cliches and I haven't quite seen it done
this way like when he's in the woods
trying to shoot her he still feels like
a very multi-layered human in that
moment who is experiencing paranoia
heartbreak fear of loss SW like I
thought he embodied the multiple layers
and he felt that's what I'm trying to
say I felt like he actually became
multi-layered and
multifaceted um at the as the movie went
and by especially by the end and that's
why I feel like he's more Human by The
End even though he's more
cold whereas in the beginning I didn't
really feel the multiple layers of this
character and it took me a while to get
actually interested in who snow this
version of snow it it really took me
some time like Rachel zler was kind of
right off the bat whereas um her uh him
took me some time and then the other
performers too of course like Peter
Dinklage was you know Peter D was kind
of doing something we were familiar with
Peter Dinklage doing but it was still
like he still committ he still Peter
nckl he's still great yeah he's still
great he's still doing the performance
and Jason schwarzman as just call him
young Stanley Tui always forget that
character's name lucky flickerman or
whatever I liked how you know the
comparison differen is Stanley Tucci is
is very much he's a superstar you know
um he's Regis filbin and then this is
Young Regis filbin you know gu's working
his way up yeah he's holding the show
together but he's also singing for his
dinner yeah yeah totally I thought J
Sportsman was excellent and yeah think
performances costumes all look great and
the aesthetic of making it like retro
sci-fi where it feels like how the 50s
and 60s imagine what the future would
look like uh so I thought that was
really cool and and yeah the third act
to me was um that that's when I felt
this movie really sang a lot and and had
the most amount of actual tension to
hold on to and and concern and worry and
I like that you don't find out what
really happened with her you keep it a
mystery with Lucy G even as The
singing's Happening the wood just a
thing that the birds are recalling above
him is this just an echo in his mind did
she really you know yeah did she even
really exist The Hunger Games head yeah
but like no like like I guess that's the
last thought that I kind of have is is
is is yeah I think the the most
important thing this movie had to do for
itself given what it's set out to do is
sell the character journey of Cory
elanus snow and I thought the most
graceful thing about it was the way they
did sort of weave in and out of moral
gray areas and you can see him in
multiple in in almost in you know the
same scene at times you know like
swaying more toward a benevolent side
swaying more toward the machinations of
the capital you know right right you
know for for as kind of straightforward
or as surface level as certain things
were it felt like that part of the story
they really always managed like I love
that thing with Peter Dinklage because
yeah you think he's just being a Snape
about it because like I knew your dad
back in the day Potter like you know I'm
going to stick it to you whereas you
know you come back around and it's like
oh this guy and that's at a point in the
story where Coro is sort of seemingly
flirting with more of a humanist
perspect or is being drawn more toward a
humanist perspective so that gives you
more cause to suspect that uh the the um
what high bottom or whatever his name is
like is a bad guy and then later on oh
you find out he's helping out the rebels
and he did this because he thinks you're
just like your dad even though you've
like tried not to be throughout this
movie but now you're still being set
down that path you know and it's and I
think we needed some depiction of the
dad that would have been nice yeah cuz
there was all this emphasis on him and I
was and I didn't really if they still
kept it so vague just something we don't
like for me you don't even need to see
his face necessarily but like show a
window into the moments where he did
have time with his dad to form any
association cuz we first meet him as
like a kid out in the snow like getting
taken in from you know squalor so like
where was how old was he when he knew
his dad like all there's questions there
I think what I never really latched on
to with the movie is why snow cares to
get this
[Music]
far cuz he's the special and his dad
created The Hunger Games but you know
like at the very beginning like of
course I'm not going to relate with this
there's got to be something there to
relate with the motivation like I think
they're trying to tell me that all this
stuff with this and his grandma he
really loves them so he wants to take
care of them is what the movie's I think
trying to tell me yeah will never be
evicted again but that wasn't I don't
know I like this specific thing you
going to lead this place this specific
thing yeah he was aspiring to at the
very jump of this movie and why are you
so inspired with ways to make the games
that much better cuz this whole thing is
predicated on like oh he's got this
crazy ass plan for how to make the games
great and I feel like we glossed over
that cuz I think there was something
there in the text about
um and maybe I missed it but feel like I
paid attention to everything the
the because it seems like the family was
once respected yeah and once of regality
in some regard and then now they're not
and he wants to reclaim that good
name I think maybe but he also seems
very detached to cult but it also seems
like everyone who finds out who his dad
is other than Peter Dinklage was like
your dad was an all right guy you know
yeah man he gave us this so I don't know
I mean but he didn't know that right not
until later I don't I thought it seemed
like he didn't know his dad gave him
till the very end yeah seems like uh he
took somehow for some reason that it's
been lost yeah not even orever or maybe
just he was never in a position to have
it revealed to him or something like
that but even such yeah it's like that's
right it's cuz the hunger gam hadn't
even happened yet cuz we started off 3
years before he gets taken in yeah 3
years before when they're like little
kids and then and then so sometime I I
guess what is it he's taken in by the
guy who would eventually create the
Hunger Games that like that part kind of
confused because we don't really ever
see him and we see Grandma or whoever
that is uh but yeah and then we cut to
10 years later or
whatever yeah because the movie starts
off three years before the first Hunger
Games yeah right it said the first
Hunger Games yeah um and then I guess
they had that conversation through a few
years before the first Hunger Games like
like that's the thing is yeah like it
would have been even if this is not
about the first Hunger Games it would
have been nice to check in with the
first Hunger Games like I feel like that
would kind of almost be important for
how close the part of the point is like
we've only been doing this for a little
while and you know they're flailing out
here we got to figure out a way to
really beef this up and and get everyone
on board and I think that would have
been I think it's be a really
challenging it's like the first the
movie The of The Purge franchise and
there's there there are correlations I
think you can draw parallels in terms of
the story and what they're talking about
and what they're doing between what the
Hunger Game stories are about and what
the purge movies are about even though
they're very different movies there's a
lot of similarities at the same time AB
um in terms of some contextual things
and and I think that would have made for
in terms of like a a thematic piece the
a more interesting thematic piece yeah
because you would see
how people like were reacting to when
this was first announced and when they
were going to do it and then how the
response went over when it went when
when it uh when it does go down yeah and
then the unknown of how how this is
supposed to
work and figure it out see that's the
thing is you could have a Hunger Games
again and and again do you know the part
of any you know continuing franchise
where we do the thing from the first
time again but you can give it a whole
new you know uh veneer and a whole new
kind of you
know set of circumstances that could
make it fresh and interesting in a more
rudimentary and rough kind of way and
tap into you know like the signature
aspect of like what Drew people to this
franchise in many ways like yeah some
some pretty straightforward but you know
very invested commentary on society in
various ways and even this like it
flirts at the end with they they either
reject Society leave and go someplace
else or they try to climb to the top and
and fix it and all that and like yeah
things were so bad and these wars
happened and we split up all these
districts and stuff and it was so bad we
had to create this game right to to make
an example but also just like Sate
people's anger and keep people
complacent and whatever else and like
and yeah like it it is odd to me not to
at least touch on that like I feel like
maybe they're just keeping that Ace up
their sleeve so if they you know want to
in another five or six years or if this
Trilogy doesn't work they can go first
Hunger Games let's get cycle three going
um but it I don't know I feel like again
for drawing it so close to that and
doing some of that I feel like you could
have just made that stuff even more Rich
by at least touching on the first games
well uh overall n you know I'd probably
give this movie uh like guess there's a
lot of things I really liked about it
though man like whenever Rachel zler was
on screen and I really did find a lot of
suspense in the last hour of this film
yeah and uh and I'm glad they put it
there like you know again in the math I
I would rather be left off on an
interesting note oh yeah rush through
act three it feels grounded and gritty
and it feels like the real world
allegories are even more present and you
put snow in a position where there are
Stakes where you like you start to semi
forget like oh yeah you're supposed to
somehow get back to the capital and
be he's stripped down I think that's
another thing that helps with the
character he's stripped down he's
vulnerable he's taken away from
everything and he's traversed all levels
of this society and he's been in favor
he's been out of favor and and in that
last half you're able to kind of live I
think one thing doing this perspective
allows you to do is live in the banality
of the daytoday of this [__] which the
third act really does do cuz he's he's a
stormtrooper the other thing I really
liked that I completely forgot to touch
on was that you actually get a sense of
community from District 12 where in in
this like movie that feels is dystopian
future you you normally don't get
something that feels joyous celebratory
in any way and you get that there when
they are and that was one of the
elements of the musical side where that
connection when they are singing and
dancing and and uh and Lucy Grace
performing I'm like oh yeah there's a
real there is a community here yeah and
you are connected and endeared to that
at least I was and I don't that's
something I don't feel the other Hunger
Games
mov you know just felt like they were
everyone's broken throwing bread in the
mud you know dreary and dirty all the
time which is part of that life but also
yeah show contr yeah and and I thought
that like finding having that kind of
community with the with with the
southern flare to it was actually pretty
cool and also you know and and to get
Rachel zegler who I I don't think she's
Caucasian uh she something she's like
Latina or something I don't know what
she is but she's obviously she's not
Caucasian and to to see someone who who
embodies such a Southern bell kind of
vibe who is not Caucasian I thought was
actually kind of was like different and
refreshing and it balances things out
cuz she is singing a lot of like very
bluesy spirituals which I think would be
kind of extra tacky if it was just like
a white girl yeah and I think some
people might be like what the hell uh
you know but I'm like all all that has
to happen is someone just grows up
around that you the voice of the cad
it's matters and the culture you know
it's like when you see like I don't know
a Japanese guy who grows up in Australia
he has an Australian accent yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly
this is this is clearly a place in which
people have been all Just jumed Around
by War in class and now you know
wherever you wind up especially her is
like a nomad you know like wherever you
wind up is sort of whatever culture
you're going to pick up like I know we
see that in life all the time uh but in
movies and shows you really don't you
know there's a uniformity that that
often happens whereas here I thought
that yeah they they they managed to make
the district feel alive and feel like
yeah despite you know the thing that all
like many places in Squad
there still can be senses of community
and ways to find joy and respit whilst
also never kind of being unaware of the
fact that you're always under the boot
th% and yeah you can feel yeah it's like
I I liked like I liked getting those
bits where you do at least just have
sort of like life's happening and people
are breaking out in song and they're
dancing and you really kind of feel like
what a day in the life is like over here
you know and what we're fighting for
yeah I can't help but think like even
though I like the third act a lot the
that there are I can't help but at times
be like
I really feel like half hour would have
added this in and maybe it's there in
the book but even even with his friend
that that's where the part I I forget
his name surgey oh so Soju something
like that the the the the the best
friendship there could have been a
heartbreaking thing if at all he did
feel compelled to help him out if he did
think like the if there was a debate
with with them truly of potentially
helping out the rebels and stuff yeah
and that way that creates a real
conflict you see him actually making a
choice that and even would drive home
that desent that character art that he
has more when he does go like no he's
shutting the [__] down he's not going to
help you know yeah and giving that car
again it's that breathing room thing of
like man just a couple more scenes
showing these guys in a joyous moment
and in a moment where you can see how
his buddy is is rubbing off on him
because he they establish that he's his
only friend you're the only guy who
sticks up for this dude who clearly has
a sympathetic side for the plees out
there you know and he speaks to his
humanity and I think you you said
something early on about certain scenes
feeling kind of soap opera esque because
the emotion has to be high because it's
the important scenes that we're cutting
to uh but I feel like especially with a
character like that like they managed to
get a good amount of the tragedy but I
feel like some of it some of the real
contrast and the real weight of it is a
bit garbled like they kind of make they
kind of streamline it in a way where
you're like yeah he's gonna betray him
whereas like you want to feel like
uh will this be less of a direct
betrayal and more of like a choice made
under one pretense only to be like oh
God no what did I do you know there
could have been more debate there and
there could have been again just a a
greater detailing of that kind of
swaying of corus's Soul between two
states and two ideologies you know yeah
and I think in a book when you're
reading a bunch of additional texts yeah
but in a movie you you got to do a
little more creative work to do some
scene work you do some sew work a little
more to drive home the plot and cuz cuz
he especially uh uh sojourn whatever his
name is is very much a a themes
character I'm here for the to bring the
themes in the text of the them and to
present those to you cor snow and I'm
like cool good like that's you need that
and I like that you know they have a
whole argument kind of their whole
ideology is like do we do direct action
or do we play the long game and and you
know what are our motivations really and
yeah it's like that stuff could have
felt a lot more lived in and you could
have felt a little less you know the the
a little less of that puppy killing
feeling when it really does come down
you know on on his head th% and the
weight of that broken promise I'll
protect you overall 7.5 for me John yeah
yeah
7.2 all right give it a s Point all
right either way I think we were both
like pleasantly surprised and like the
the good stuff was better than expected
and the stuff that doesn't work could
have worked stuff I did not show up for
all were the things that I thought were
the best parts great surpr great surise
all the stuff I did not care
about before end I was like oh damn this
is actually the most interesting well of
all the people like just bound to a
franchise well done Francis Lawrence and
Company yeah but I think you should move
on uh I think all these dudes need to
move on I think you
should all righty guys leave your
thoughts down below what you thought
Hunger Games ballot of song birds and
snakes and and uh hey before we go let's
end this with a
p Ana Oliva Ana it is
2024 oh and I was thinking about
it in the year of Co oh which you know
it's still very much real but in still
out there but in the year when you know
the pandemic was at its Heights out here
in the
states I remember we would do live
streams and you were contributing
boatloads of cash you were like ready to
go broke yeah and I just feel like you
don't really do that anymore yeah it's
been a long time and part of me is
wondering why we should still be
shouting you out I mean yeah you you
pledge for this but what is that I mean
that's just to get in the door you know
that's just the cover chart but now we
have an we have an expectation bar of
what to receive from your end and the
bar only ever rides it's really limits
the passion behind the shout outs
for when we're not financially
incentivized for the bonus that it could
lead to a more stimulating shout out
comes from more stimulating stimulus
package and I'm not dropping a hint here
I'm not saying what you should
do there are a could and would scenario
here that could be happening and ought
to
mandatory but hey hey
I'm no gaslighter all right I didn't
hear nothing G I'm no manipulator around
here so I I can't tell you what to do
with your funds no no no never but I'm
just saying it's a new year it's just
friendly advice you know and um the
pandemic height was a while ago and we
went through all the
2023 well you risked your life out there
and now we're in 2024 I'm just hoping
that well in 2023 where you like saving
up stock here to dish out monthly cuz
she knew it was going to come back and
then she would start showering us again
to protect us from the all the antigens
outside I'm not I'm not not suggesting
just you know just implying just uh
throwing a
thought just spitball in here right just
spitball in here go with me on this
that's your you do what you want to do
yeah you know you're a independent woman
do what you want yeah and the great
thing is so often your interest and
needs align perfectly with ours so that
makes us Independent Women too just
saying give us give us a lot more give
us some money give us a lot more get
pledge more find the streamlabs link go
there and I'm also offline Super Chat
saying to let me be clear that if you do
end up sending us a lot more money due
to this shout
out we are going to be filled with
obnoxious amounts of guilt so please
don't do it not actually the disclaimer
this is not a serious shout out normally
I would really just stick to the B but
we can put a long zoom on it so clear
that this is a joke we know you pretty
well and I'm I feel like this joke could
really go badly and you would be like oh
[__] I better send them please don't
just that you have been here for as long
as you have and have been as lovely for
as long as the greatest gift please
don't do it so yeah we don't need it
for you've been amazing and yep let's
get through a tough period on the
channel so thank you and I'll never
forget that and we've of course gotten
to know you as a actual human being and
person and you've been wonderful gym so
I hope in 2024 uh that you are able to
use money to invest so that way you
could just have pure Financial Freedom
stocks and also I hope you get married
this year hope you find a guy marry him
he better worst things you can do with
your money worst things you could do
with your money
[Music]